uh good afternoon thank you all for
being here today it's uh
cold outside up here compared to
southern nevada and it's a
refreshing day i'm glad to be back in
northern nevada
uh this week and glad to be here today
to talk about this very important topic
that we're going to get into
earlier this month the nevada department
of health and human services
submitted a draft of our state-specific
plan
or we call our playbook as we refer to
it for covid19 vaccine planning
for the cdc center for disease control
this high-level planning document which
is subject to review
and final approval from the cdc was a
tremendous effort between a number of
stakeholders
to make sure that the mat is prepared
when a vaccine becomes available
and to make it clear that's when a
vaccine becomes available we do not have
a vaccine currently
the nevada playbook is a living document
meaning we will adapt and adjust as your
role vaccine response
develops and up until the vaccine is
deemed safe and effective by the food
and drug
administrations i know a lot of nevadans
have been following this topic with a
great deal of interest
so have i and i know that there's a lot
of unknowns and a great deal of
misinformation
about covin19 and the potential vaccines
against the virus are currently
circulating
i want to be very clear with nevadans
there are still many unknowns
before a vaccine is finalized and ready
for distribution
but i also want nevadans to know the
state has been planning for months
and the state will be ready when the
time comes we will be prepared
when the time comes it is natural for
the public to have questions about a new
vaccine
and the state of nevada is committed to
transparency regarding
vaccine planning and expectations that's
why i'm joined today by two of our
experts in the vaccine planning
team that you'll be hearing from shortly
candace mcdaniel from the health bureau
chief
of the bureau of child family and
community wellness division of public
health and behavioral health is with me
as well as shannon bennett immunization
program manager
division of public and behavioral health
what we do know is there is no approved
vaccine at this time
i want to repeat that there is no
approved vaccine at this time
there's a lot of speculation but there's
no definitive timeline
for one one may be approved but we want
to ensure that upon approval
nevada has a system in place for the
distribution
and administration of a safe vaccine
as the supply becomes available
vaccination planning is not new to the
state of nevada
we are fortunate to have an existing
framework
that is managed by a team of experts who
work on these efforts on a day-to-day
basis
with other programs such as vaccines for
children
and the flu shot program which we're
dealing with right now
and i want to while we're on the flu
shot program i want to encourage
everyone who has not gotten a flu
vaccine
please go and get one soon
we're getting in the winter months where
the flu vaccine is extremely important
i know there's a lot of areas around
town where you can get it and i
encourage everyone to please go get out
get your flu vaccine with that i will
turn it over to our team members who
have been working diligently
on our planning efforts after ms
mcdaniel and ms bennett speak we'll have
some time to answer questions about a
covet vaccine
ladies thank you for the introduction
and opportunity to talk today about the
nevada state immunization program
and the co-advisor 19 vaccine plan my
name is candice mcdaniel and i serve as
the bureau chief for the child family
community wellness
and the department of health and human
services as the governor said at this
time
a coven-19 vaccine has not yet been
approved
while we do not have the vaccine to
distribute we have been focusing on the
plan for how the vaccine will be
allocated
within our state and talking with key
partners
about the process we anticipate only
receiving a small number of doses to
begin with
and our program has developed an outline
of priority populations
based on their level of exposure this
framework is based in science
using the information we now and have
and it focuses on our frontline medical
professionals first
with priority consideration for those
who are in close and sustained contact
with individuals who have coven 19.
while we cannot speak to decisions being
made by federal agencies
such as the fda or the cdc
we can ensure that we have a plan in
place for nevadans
nevada's playbook was submitted to the
cdc on the 16th
and it is our framework it is a living
document
and we will add to it and adjust as more
is known
the plan is like a frame of a house and
it sets the structure
but now we need to furnish it and attend
to the details
our goal is to be as prepared as
possible when the vaccine becomes
available in our state
it is important to know that working
with immunizing providers
distributing vaccine and tracking doses
are not new to dhhs and the immunization
program
we have an established system in place
and a staff who work on these activities
every day and we have reviewed the
lessons we learned
during the h1n1 flu pandemic in 2009
the nevada web ic system has been in
existence for years
and it is widely used by nevada's
immunizing providers
and nevada state law requires that all
vaccines given must be entered into the
system
this system is used for our vaccines for
children program
vaccine requests are documented and
reviewed by our staff
and providers already use this system to
manage vaccine
inventories it will be used to manage
and distribute
covid19 vaccine in the same way
shannon bettit will now talk about the
federal process of approval
for the vaccine
thank you candace my name is shannon
bennett and i am the immunization
program manager
in the division of public and behavioral
health as we said
the timing for an approved covin-19
vaccine remains unknown
but the process for approval remains the
same
high standard as has always been used
for vaccines
the vaccine goes through several levels
of clinical trials
each including more individuals who are
monitored for side effects and the
effectiveness of immunization
people of different ages races and
ethnic ethnicities are included in the
clinical trials even on the accelerated
timeline of coven 19.
there are currently no trials including
children
or pregnant women and we do not expect a
vaccine for those groups until clinical
trials are expanded to include them
in order to meet the aggressive timeline
of the federal government's operation
warp speed
coven 19 vaccine is being manufactured
while it is still
in the clinical trial phase this is the
main reason that a vaccine will be
available for distribution as soon as
the manufacturer can present a strong
case
to the fda for emergency use licensure
however if the vaccine is not deemed
safe and effective by the fda
then it will not be released for use we
know
vaccine hesitancy is in the news a lot
and people have concerns but we can be
confident
that a vaccine will not be released if
it has not been deemed safe and affected
by the fda and the cdc's advisory
committee on immunization practices
during and following the clinical trial
the vaccine is reviewed by three
national independent review boards these
independent groups make the final
determination
of if a vaccine is licensed and will
develop recommendations for use in
certain population groups like people
with comorbidities and underlying health
conditions
to develop nevada's coven 19 vaccine
plan
we had to consider a variety of factors
to be
prepared for the different vaccines when
they become available
some criteria may change but from what
we know
there will be new challenges relating to
storing and handling and distributing
this vaccine
the coven 19 vaccine distribution will
involve
challenges such as
to prepare for a variety of distribution
scenarios
when the vaccine becomes available and
we have information on the amount of
vaccine allocated to nevada
again we want to stress that initial
supplies of vaccine are expected to be
limited
and therefore will be prioritized for
populations most at risk
to for exposure to coven 19. we are
committed
to equitable equitable distribution of a
safe vaccine
following directives based on science
thank you thank you very much uh we will
also be including
vaccination updates as much as possible
on our press calls
at task force meetings or at my future
news conferences
additionally the full vaccination
playbook that was submitted to the cdc
will be made available after this press
conference it will be made public
finally i also want to take this
opportunity to follow up
on our covet numbers on saturday
this past saturday the state reported
over 1 000
cases for the first time since july
for the first time since july we had
over a thousand
positive cases as of today
eight of nevada's 17 counties have been
flagged for elevated disease
transmission
11 counties have more than 200 cases
per 100 000 over a 30-day period
eight counties have a positivity
percentages over eight percent
four counties are over 10 percent
while nevada's healthcare infrastructure
continues to be moderately
impacted by covet 19 hospitalizations we
know from experience that in increasing
cases
ultimately leads to an increase in
hospitalizations
200 cases per 100 000 over a 30-day
period
eight counties have a positivity
percentages over eight percent
four counties are over 10 percent
while nevada's healthcare infrastructure
continues to be moderately impacted by
covid19 hospitalizations
we know from experience that in
increasing cases
ultimately leads to an increase in
hospitalizations
and unfortunately oftentimes translates
into an
increase in deaths there's proof of this
around the country right now
including some of our fellow western
states where we're seeing
hospitalization
hospitalizations reach dangerous press
record-setting levels
potential care rationing has taken place
in some of these areas
they're transporting patients in some of
these areas to other states that might
have capacity available for
hospitalization
and they're doing everything they can to
make sure that everybody gets care but
that is what we are looking at
folks i don't know how to make this
clear this is real
it would be irresponsible of me for to
say that our state
to minimize the risk that our state is
currently facing
we're not rounding the curve we as
nevadans have some tough choices to make
and we're going to make them together
right now i am working on a plan
to increase capacity to fifty percent
for conventions
beginning january first of twenty twenty
one
to get business back to the state and
nevadans back to work
this will help us on our job situation
in terms of employing people
the business side the people that are
coming for these conventions
can provide business to our local and
our uh resort
businesses and the tax revenue that will
be
derived as a result of that so it is my
goal
and we're working towards increasing the
capacity for conventions
to by january 1st of this year
next year 2021. i'm working with the
health officials and education leaders
to determine
how we can get all of nevada's students
back into the classroom
as soon and as safe as possible in a
responsible manner
we're working with all 17 school
districts
to get our kids back in classrooms to
begin their learning experiences again
these are just some of the goals we're
working on
but whether or not we get there is not a
matter of luck
it's not a matter of chance it's not a
matter we'll see what happens
it's a matter of each and every one of
you
we need the public's help and
cooperation
to make this possible and i speak to
people
every day my wife speaks to people every
day my kids do
if you want to be able to go see your
grandson
playing their fifth grade basketball
game if you want to go see your
granddaughter
in a play or graduate from eighth grade
or whatever it might be or get an
academic award or an athletic
achievement
if you want to be able to go see an
athletic event
if you want to be able to go to a
professional event a vegas golden
knights game or a
raiders game someday it's all up to you
you are the deciding factor of whether
or not we can make this happen
and i'm going to ask for your help again
i'm going to ask for your help
you have to make a choice today to make
a choice this week
and in the months ahead of us do you
care more about your child returning to
in-person learning
than you do to attending that halloween
costume party
you care more about returning to your
job than having a gathering at your home
with no social distancing or no masking
because those are the choices we have to
make those are your choices
those are our choices students
i choose our jobs but i need all of
nevadans to make those choices with me
to make those our priorities
so i'm going to say the following on
repeat and it's not the first time that
i've said
it and i know that some of you get tired
of hearing it i know you're dealing with
covet fatigue
so am i but this is a time we have to
double down we have to do more
so this is what i'm asking of you
we need to wear face coverings it is not
a political
statement to wear a face covering it
protects others
it protects your loved ones it protects
your family other people wear a mask to
protect you
i'm asking you to wear a mask to protect
them
i'm asking you to practice social
distancing
six feet stay six feet apart
wash your hands use hand sanitizer
avoid crowds avoid large public
gatherings
private and public gatherings
if you're sick if you're not feeling
good
if you think you might have been exposed
if you're feeling under the weather
stay home please stay
home do not intake the potential
impact of impacting infecting someone
else because you're not feeling good
too many people say i just thought i was
feeling under i thought it was a cold
maybe it's not a cold if you're not
feeling good please stay home
get a test if you have had a positive
contact or you are feeling any symptoms
get a test tests are available readily
the turnaround time is quick and it'll
help all of us
especially this flu season more
important than ever right now
get your flu shot if you haven't gotten
in the past
i went my wife and i went it's painless
it's easy it's convenient
save our hospitals it will prevent
burden from coming down on our hospitals
where people don't know if they've got
cova they've got the flu
and we've got our emergency rooms
overwhelmed with people with flu
symptoms
please do your part get a flu shot
and i'm going to repeat one more time
i'm asking you
the choice is yours i'm choosing kids
i'm choosing schools i'm choosing jobs
i'm choosing nevada families please
wear a face covering practice social
distancing
wash your hands avoid large public and
private gatherings
and if you're sick please stay home
thank you very much and i'd be happy to
take some questions if anybody's got any
we ask that you guys come up to this
podium and uh i think there's a button
to turn the mic
on and uh if we can keep it to one
question at a time looks like we should
be able to go through a few
hi governor good to see you how are you
so under the cares act the federal
government has allocated nevada 1.8
million
or 60 cents per resident for vaccine
distribution
with talks in congress over a new relief
package stalled does nevada dhss have
enough money to distribute a vaccine on
its own
as we are allocated vaccines
we will make sure that that those
vaccines can be distributed
to our community i'm hopeful that
there'll be more karazhak money coming
after we get into another
legislative round i guess in washington
d.c
but we will make sure that those
vaccines are distributed to nevada
residents do you agree with senator
harris that it'll only be safe to take a
vaccine when dr fauci says
rather than when the white house says
well i'm depending i'm relying upon the
fda the cdc
the medical experts and scientific
experts i am not relying on politicians
that say it's safe whoever they might be
i'm going to rely on our elected or our
health professionals our scientists our
doctors to determine
what's safe residents are people thanks
thanks sam we'll go to the next question
um you mentioned wanting to get the
conventions to 50
capacity by the beginning of the year
what do the numbers
need to look like for us to get to that
point well i don't have
set in stone numbers that they need to
get to i look at more as uh
trends in our hospital system
it's extremely important we've gotten
increasing cases but thank goodness
there's not been a
significant increase in hospitalizations
or commensurate increase in
hospitalizations as a result of that
uh that's my goal 50 by january 1st but
we're not going to get there by flipping
a coin we're going to get there if
everybody is willing to put in the hard
work
to get us there which involves the
protocols that i set in place earlier
if it's important to you that we get our
kids back in school if it's important to
you that we get our conventions of 50
we're a mask practice social distancing
so i'm hopeful we'll be able to get
there by january 1st
we've been on an uptick in a lot of the
trends especially a lot of the metrics
if this continues through november and
december is
would you would you still be looking to
put conventions at 50
companies well i've had discussions with
the
resort partners they know that a lot of
this is going to be dependent on
data that we get coming in prior to that
and data that we get at that time
i'm hopeful that we'll be on a downtrend
by that time i'm hopeful that there'll
be a vaccine available at that time
i've got a lot of hopes but reality is
going to come at the end of december
when we find out where we're really at
but
understand you you've got to understand
a lot of these conventions plan months
in advance
and you know i don't want to lose the
whole first quarter and second quarter
of next year
nobody does it better than nevada does
and i'm confident that the resorts have
i've seen the protocols that they're
putting in place
in order to handle these conventions
these meetings and i'm confident that
they can get people here safely
i don't want to get people here and
getting sick it's only going to work if
we can get them here safely on
if we can get them into these properties
and take care of them once they're there
and i'm confident that we have a
protocol in place and hopefully our
numbers will allow us to proceed with
that
if we're not on a downward trend will
you hold off on that well i don't want
to play the if game i'm confident that
we're going to be in a downward trend
because i
really believe i believe in the people
of the state of nevada
i believe that they want to open these
conventions you know i believe that they
want their kids to go back to school in
clark county in the classroom
i believe that that's what they want i
believe their grandparents want to see
their grandkids
i i i firmly believe that the vast
majority
of our residents of nevadans want that
to happen
and if they practice the protocols that
we have in place i'm confident that
we'll get there
thanks colton let's go to the next
question and let's try to keep it to one
question at a time please
governor you advise nevadans to avoid
public and private gatherings large
public and private gatherings
in counties where gatherings of up to
250 people are allowed
is it safe to go is the question is it
safe to go to a gathering with 250
people
yeah yeah i would prefer that together
and be outdoors
i would prefer that obviously if you
have the gathering you still have to
practice social distancing
you still have to wear a mask you still
have to do the protocols that are in
place
but 250 and hopefully it's not for an
extended period of time
i think sam will go to the next question
governor you have three businesses in
northern nevada that are being fined for
having larger than
approved events without getting
permission to do so and you have
several political rallies that are going
that are larger
and you're depending upon nevadans to do
the right thing
is some type of stricter enforcement
going to be required eventually because
you've got businesses
and you've got even individuals that
don't care
about the requirements and the
restrictions and what you're looking for
and i'm really glad you asked that
question unfortunate that we have a
uh a small minority of individuals that
don't care
that are going to have these events and
going to have them without
protocols without social distancing
without masks
and they are going to impact innocent
people
and they will be infected as a result of
someone's
poor behavior we do have
osha has fined some operations who have
chose to
knowingly not comply with our
protocols that we have in place you know
as well as i do we've got several coming
in the next week
with uh candidates coming surrogates
coming
there's a lot of rallies coming with
eight days left to go that's great i
want every
i want everyone to participate in this
election
whoever you support it's not about who
you support
but it's about supporting nevadans it's
about supporting the health
of the people that live in the state of
nevada if you're coming to nevada as a
guest
follow our protocols 250 people means
250 people
it doesn't mean 2 000 people it doesn't
mean that you think this event is exempt
from being a super spreading event
because it's not
you're coming here as a guest you're
welcome we enjoy having you here
but when you're here follow our rules
can i ask one more question sure go
ahead utah
is to the east of us and is at 100
maximum you said that some states are
transporting patients outside of
states to get the help they need is
anybody sitting there any other state
sending their patients here to nevada to
get treatment
uh currently the only ones that we have
are border state you know ones where we
have some on the board of arizona some
in california where it's the nearest
hospital
we don't have any plan in place right
now for any states to send
patients as a matter of course but i
know i talked to these governors a lot
of them are really struggling right now
governor herbert is struggling uh
governor grisham it's difficult when the
hospital is
so important that everyone does their
part and we keep this capacity available
in the hospitals
these front line workers these medical
workers i'm telling you folks
are doing an amazing job they are saving
lives
and we need to do our small part in
order to help them
continue to save those lives thank you
governor thank you
thanks we'll do one more from colton and
one more from sam and don't forget we
have miss mcdaniel and miss bennett here
to talk to vaccine planning as well
so on the vaccine um you mentioned
both of you mentioned that there is some
hesitation from the public about getting
a vaccine once it becomes available
is the state planning on any kind of
campaign or any kind of
basically some sort of a campaign to
inform or persuade the public to get it
once it is available
yes we will be working with partners
across the state
including our statewide immunization
coalition immunize nevada to get
messaging out
when a safe and effective vaccine is
available
we'll do the last question from sam
before we wrap up my questions for
shannon
so one of the questions that the
national governors association had for
the cdc was about ultra cold storage
which you mentioned in a potential dry
ice shortage is there
fear or worry about that in nevada
what's our
current capacity with dry ice thank you
for the question it's it's a good one
i feel like we talk a lot about ultra
cold storage these days
so we do have a plan in place we have
identified ultracold freezers in three
locations across the state
and we'll be able to redistribute
vaccine from those ultra cold freezers
in quantities that will fit rural nevada
because that's been one of the
big logistical questions in dealing with
this entire
vaccine distribution planning so there
is a plan in place
why is rural nevada more difficult
because
there's a minimum order of 975 doses for
that particular vaccine so rural nevada
is concerning just because there's
smaller numbers out there
less concerned with las vegas and reno
for that piece thank you
thank you great thank you thank you
everybody for coming we appreciate it
and again
please please everybody choose
our kids choose our families choose our
jobs
wear a mask in social distance thank you